[Music]
and shut the [ __ ] up news man I've been
- submitted by Pollyanna the Joel malian
pollyana a Filipino town has banned
gossip in a bid to stop rumors from
spreading impossible Philippines are you
[ __ ] crazy that's what keeps the
culture alive it's in their DNA yeah
I can't help it I had to talk about
somebody can you imagine a town-hall
meeting they're gonna start off with did
you hear we have to stop gossiping with
gossip wind should we stop or start I
don't know
time's up they have made gossip illegal
under a new local impossible [ __ ]
emboss impossible did you have a night
of gossip like the purge where everyone
can get once a year so good gotta be
slow about razor said excuse me busy
waiting waiting for a bear these
speakeasies and she [ __ ] password all
these pitas are around [ __ ] gossipy
it's all soundproof they're gonna sell
it because I cannot gossip I'm only
going to tell the truth of all the [ __ ]
that I was like like guarantee our
Filipino friends at home were laughing
yeah it's like making them to stop
singing you can't do it you might as
well tell my teacher not to dance why
did you make it but it sounds very
Jamaican me not to spread rumors it's
like telling me that the breathe don't
express yourself they're trying to stop
rumors from spreading within the
community and so they're saying that
first time gossiper offenders first time
offenders
they will risk a fine of 200 pesos which
is about three dollars and 80 cents and
three years is a lot for them they'll
probably well you came in strong and
ended soft would love for them kind of
probably you know why is because he
realized that it could be slightly
offensive yeah
David so move right there I could
recognize that from a distance yeah [ __ ]
those people because you know what it is
I'm not talking about the light-skinned
filipinos out there that's what it is if
it's a Guardian Filipino for sure your
pace is a lot what I learned yeah so
it's either $200 pesos or three hours of
collecting garbage in the street you say
got a [ __ ] now you collect all the
gossip happens though like what was the
last straw what was like the gossip
they're like yeah like crack the balloon
[Laughter]
so the mayor cited rumors of residents
relationships or financial situations as
examples of punishable offenses but
they're not super clear on what is
qualified as gossip so they're trying to
hide something
did you hear about Lauren what I heard
that she is actually power did you see
the new bag that she bought I heard she
bought it because of she's been naughty
so you know how you guys are like this
is impossible it will never work who
said that you guys all set it well same
neighborhood of that town that we're
talking about now so they have been
enforcing no gossiping since 2017 and
multiple residents have been fined 500
pesos which is about ten dollars and
they were forced to spend an afternoon
collecting trash as punishment but there
has never been a second offense you know
why publicly you know why because they
catch all the gossipers cuz you know why
gossipers can't hold the truth in so if
the cops come after you be like who told
you this well you know what I'm not
supposed to say it but I what is really
going to do
though is going to expose a lot of
people who can't develop healthy
relationships with people because there
are a lot of people that I personally
know the only way that they connect with
somebody else is by gossiping all the
way they had nothing to offer because
they don't know they have nothing going
on in their lives
yeah gossip is fun I'm gonna eat we're
gossiping right now nothing to do with
us I am not gossiping what if this is
more like this imagine who's a gossip
police they're gonna go over there that
caught you gossiping what gossiping is
fun you know what I mean it's like now
you have to pay or or pay me a little
bit right now I don't know there's I
think to me there's a difference between
Gaza and then if that person tells
somebody else about the cop is out of
your gospel you know what is the
difference between gossiping and just
talking about [ __ ] right because one is
roasting and one is gossiping yeah cuz I
couldn't because that continually roast
maybe it's a falsifier spreading of
misinformation right well it depends
because it's like you're sharing hate
right or you're sharing misinformation
potentially could be yeah our defamation
yeah like you're ruining someone's
reputation but sometimes that's fun
though so they're saying that they're
trying to protect members of the
community from slander I think that
means that members of the community have
things to hide I remember some damaging
rumors that hurt our family at the
church and things like that and in
rumors and gossip really became so
damaging that the pastor actually had to
do a whole sermon and kind of shame the
ladies but no none of the old ladies
think that they're doing it for sure
people just do it an awesome present
even though they don't know that they're
doing it but they're it's like a drug
right like it's almost like they get a
high off of like talking about other
people yeah I don't know that I'm
addicted
I love gossip that's just fun one
because it's fun to hear about stuff
that's interesting well you're a
different type of gossiper cuz I'm sure
you're not spreading it around and it's
not far you're spreading them love
secrets
everyone loves that's true when it's
made up secrets that's when it's
dangerous yeah it's like did you know so
and so I'm saying I think somebody's got
so many heart
what in history the idea of like a
a government or anything like silencing
people or saying that you're gonna be
punished for saying things or any times
usually something that has to do with
the cover-up
what do you try to cover up there yeah
please Andy I'll talk to you later
all right cool like the mayor try to
cover up the banana missing problem or
whatever in the village like someone
kept stealing the bananas or whatever
yeah and it's the mayor and salsa is
like all I'm hearing these rumors gossip
to me a bus [ __ ] that I don't care about
my clap that just be like oh did you
hear about this purchase no like I could
give a [ __ ] less just swipe topics
detect next thing what do you guys think
what else what else do you have here
did you hear that's exciting Peter Kim
and what he did to his wife I was like I
don't like Peter he could go die let's
move on I like gossip where someone did
something stupid and you can't wait to
tell me that's what it stops with you
right
well after you tell us if it reminds me
like like I say you told me something
about your dad right that he did funny
yeah if I'm having a conversation with
someone else and then like let's say it
pertains to that then I would bring it
up yeah yeah yeah unless it's like a
[ __ ] secret like I don't know but
usually we don't have secrets no really
oh oh I have a lot yeah you piece of
[ __ ] what are they prove it tell us your
secrets prove it some secrets are juicy
enough where you're like like you're
about to tell someone and don't tell me
I don't want to pick up trash yeah and
you're like but it's about this topic
count y'all just counting that the
amount of pesos yeah you're like [ __ ] it
he's worthless
just paying for information like having
them have a lot like you can't name your
kid RJ aj rj @ pj d j FJ i know if i
don't abbreviate their name what am I
supposed to do say they're all named
impossible I feel like some people have
like meetings just so they can talk [ __ ]
it's like go when you have tea so
there's a lot of [ __ ] talking we need to
do about her friends and [ __ ] yeah
that's called girl gatherings yeah this
is this is a fun fact but you can
basically tell what type of personality
someone has based off of how they
explain who their friends are so if if
you ask
I'm like Oh what kind of friends you
have and then they'll say like all my
friends are [ __ ] dope like they're
they're doing this they're doing that
like they're like they're loving they're
awesome versus some people like man I
got shady friends the whole world is a
shady place that means you're a terrible
person it does because people are just
projecting and reflecting who they are
and in what they see they observe in
other people so for example like let's
say you bought a new car right and then
all of a sudden you notice that car all
over the road it's always been there but
you never noticed it before but now you
feel like oh my god this [ __ ] is Chevy
Camaro is all over the place I didn't
realize how many existed right that's
the same thing is like you see the world
in a shady place or you see it in the
shady light when you yourself are shady
person
shady recognized shady BAM I just wanna
say I love everyone and you guys are
great people but now that you know this
fact guilty but if you know this fact
people can prove a point guys you know
Boyd [ __ ] you don't mean what you just
said I think most of you guys prove all
yeah except for Bart right we'll call it
will gossip later yeah but that would
people can now mask it when they notice
information they could mask their
personality by saying you're positive
[ __ ] you'll see it you don't have to do
a backhanded compliment or so always
leak seen the Ted Bundy thing recently
you want to wait the narrative or the
documentary both I watched a documentary
oh you were just trying to survey that's
it okay I can't watch it cuz I'm a big
fan of his music I don't affect the
music by gaudí the whole thing was about
him being so like to the T like sticking
to his innocence in such a charming way
that like people were super perplexed by
it so it's just he's a sociopath he
can't say that he did it you have to do
it in third person and that's the only
way he got they got him to confess
that's how they got him on his
confession tapes because genius so he
wouldn't he would never admit to
anything because he doesn't believe he
did it
but his alter ego did it or if he were
to do it he'll tell you how that's what
they said I said if you were to do it
how would you do it and then that's how
he confessed everything
confessed it to the tea oh he goes like
to Nick like two days before he was
gonna die or something like that right
yeah oh he goes well what you say in the
first place
case closed Ted Bundy L buddies brother
yeah I hope you thought that as a kid
[Music]
[Music]